meu nome é alexandre gaio alho mesmo de
tempero de cozinha todo mundo me chama
esse nome na universidade é lógico né
minha vida inteira brincaram com esse
meu nome imagina tudo canta aquela que
você pode imaginar já fizeram comigo e
eu o que eu quero falar aqui né
a idéia de falar de sustentabilidade
ainda é meio complicado a gente fala
muito hoje em dia mas ser sustentável
não é muito simples né a gente viu
diversos exemplos aqui durante a manhã e
na verdade eu quero falar sobre o que os
barquinhos tem a ver com isso eu vou até
uma canoa é aqui pra gente ver o calor
aqui é bastante sustentável né
os materiais que a gente usa para fazer
essa canoa são materiais renováveis da
natureza mas isso não é muito trivial
quando a gente pensa na indústria naval
que é uma grande vilã em termos de
poluição
então eu quero discutir com vocês aqui
um pouco eu quero discutir alguns
valores que eu acho importante acho que
esse tema que transcende a questão de
falar de barco e falar de sustentar a
sustentabilidade claro que é importante
mas como é que a garotada a rapaziada
vejo aqui muitos rocha ou china é todo
mundo joga aqui com a disposição da nova
gm é uma forma correndo pra lá e pra cá
pra cá eu não tenho mais essa disposição
é eu ficaria sentado está tudo resolvido
é só entrar e falar eu quero é eu quero
só discutir alguns alguns conceitos que
é o que eu tento de bater na aula com a
rapaziada seja a universidade vai além
do ensino
eu acho que a gente tem que debater
conceitos valores eu acho que isso é
importante então vamos lá muito bem eu
peguei aqui uma coisa que me rigorosa no
brasil a gente não gosta muito de coisas
que são né rigorosas codificadas mas
aquela lei no brasil que rege a inovação
que o tema aqui da minha palestra é uma
lei lei de inovação ali 2004 e 14 anos
regulamentada em 2005 e tem umas coisas
interessantes nessa lei a gente olha o
que é inovação para a lei a introdução
de uma novidade o aperfeiçoamento a
gente quando a gente fala em inovação
todo mundo tem que fazer uma coisa nova
mas esse novo a gente pode só
aperfeiçoar que às vezes é até melhor o
que já existe do que revolucionou o
mundo e vou fazer tudo de novo
além disso o seguinte a gente pode
aplicar isso que no ambiente produtivo
que é isso empresa no ambiente social as
pessoas então inovação não significa só
revolucionar o mundo eventualmente a
gente tentar fazer algo absolutamente
novo e fazer com que tudo seja diferente
a partir de então
e aí eu gosto do primeiro conselho que
eu quero colocar a gente tem que pensar
grande mas trabalhar com as formiguinhas
pequenininho né
a formiga faz um formigueiro desse
tamanho mas ela bota um grãozinho de
areia de cada vez
usando a saliva dela a gente às vezes
que é logo fazer tudo de uma vez só
principalmente quando a gente é jovem a
gente quer resolver tudo de uma vez só
talvez seja um dos motivos é de
ansiedade então esse é o primeiro
desafio é lá o desafio de inovar de
forma sustentável
isso é um desafio porque esse é um
desafio vou pegar aqui duas coisas que
eu acho importante aqui é que todo mundo
sabe fazer desde sempre casa e barco
sempre brinco com isso porque a gente
faz casa ea gente faz barulho desde
antes diante de existir a engenharia que
explica como é que a gente faz casa
explica como é que a gente vai para
então fazer casa e barco quase intuitivo
a gente vê no meio da floresta com frio
a gente vai de alguma forma de proteger
a gente vê que atravessar o rio pra
comer a gente vai dar um jeito para
atravessar o rio para comer e trazer a
comida do outro lado tanto que lá todo
dia um agente aqui um barquinho lá que
vai ajudar a gente fazer mais coisas
isso é bom é lógico que isso é bom
porque cada um passa a ser o que é um
elemento inovador
eu quero resolver um problema e eu posso
renovar resolvendo esse problema mas
porque isso pode ser ruim também é isso
que a gente tem que tomar muito cuidado
na minha opinião porque sem conhecimento
a gente só tem entusiasmo isso é uma
falha que muita gente comete eu já
cometi quando era jovem às vezes desde
quando eu também cometo depois burro
velho
a gente fica muito entusiasmado em fazer
a mudança hoje em dia a gente é muito
estimulado em fazer mudanças em inovar
só que a gente está no século 21 a gente
já tem 150 anos de conhecimento
científico não dá pra gente ficar só no
entusiasmo
a gente tem que ter conhecimento
reconhecimento só o conhecimento
científico o conhecimento amplo da vida
do mundo das coisas da vida
coisas do mundo e logicamente o
conhecimento acadêmico o conhecimento
científico que não dá pra gente
simplesmente tento use água pelas coisas
rock e eu vou fazer um comentário não
seja lá no passado quando todo mundo
fazer a barba a gente fazia barulho de
que de madeira usando vela de algodão
nós éramos extremamente sustentáveis na
roma antiga
a madeira renovável ou algodão também aí
a gente resolveu inovar
a gente quer transportar mais carga
ganha mais dinheiro é ter mais gente
para alimentar a nós fizemos um navio de
aço movido a motor diesel
aí a gente começou a poluir um cadeia
novação tem mas ela é sustentável
não porque a gente não tinha o que
conhecimento conhecimento do impacto que
aquela inovação causaria na nossa vida e
no mundo
e hoje a gente vive o resultado desse
impacto estão querendo voltar
o barco de madeira no mundo foi uma
coisa que há dez anos atrás praticamente
desapareceu porque todo mundo está
preocupado com as florestas
só que a gente faz barco de fibra de
vidro que não é o material reciclável
então hoje em dia tudo pensando vamos
fazer o seguinte vou fazer uma floresta
sustentável e voltar a fazer barraco de
madeira até porque são lindos muito mais
bonito que os barcos e filho então
percebe a gente tem que ter o
conhecimento
então vamos lá então eu falei ou de
barco então vamos falar de baixo e por
que eu estou querendo falar um pouco de
barro porque a indústria naval é uma
indústria que é muito grande
noventa por cento do que a gente
comercializa é transportado por navios
olha só a 90% só que navio polui muito
cara vamos ver vamos fazer uma corrente
rápida aqui um aviãozinho de se quem
estiver passeando aqui na costa do rio
de janeiro ele chega gastam em torno de
4 toneladas de combustível por hora por
hora multiplica pra ver a quantidade de
co2 que ele joga na atmosfera
e esse combustível é um combustível que
sobra do refino do petróleo é um
combustível muito sujo muito mais sujo
que aquilo que a gente coloca
nós só tomou então o nível de poluição
que ele gera não só pelo volume mas pela
qualidade da poluição é muito pior
muito maior o nível de poluição foi
então vamos resolver esse problema vamos
inovar vão ser sustentáveis vão mudar a
forma como os navios navegam vão morrer
de fome porque 90% do que a gente come
do que a gente transporta tente navio
então tem outra verdade que a gente não
pode esquecer se o navio é grande
o problema é grande se o que eu quero a
gente resolver é uma indústria grande
algo grande
o problema é grande e aí nós vamos
voltar pra 'formiguinha' esse grande
trabalho pequeno vamos aqui no início
aqui o primeiro que o slide ou seja
reconstruir o mundo e entre parênteses
ao rei depois construir
eu quero fazer uma pequena contribuição
vamos construir tiro recebe porque é uma
coisa que a gente reconstrói que a gente
acabou de fazer o mundo não acabou de
fazer nós estamos construindo eo que é a
cada instante a cada dia então não vai
reconstruir nada a gente tá só
construindo às vezes erra mais rápido
mas devagar a gente tá só construindo na
minha opinião para construir a gente tem
que ter essa grande vão fazer um mundo
sustentável fazer com que os navios
sejam sustentáveis transporte né 300 mil
toneladas de alguma carga de forma
sustentável
mas como é que a gente consegue ir
trabalhando pequeno por exemplo um barco
pequeno porque o problema é pequeno que
é o caso da indústria o náutico que
apesar de ser um barquinho pequeno mas
movimenta 30 milhões vai movimentar e
espera-se que movimente no mundo 30
bilhões de dólares em 2022 ou seja é
algo também que vai mexer com bastante
gente mas aí a gente tem um outro
problema que a outra só a gente que
tenta resolver as coisas desafios vão
chegando e como é que um novo de maneira
sustentável e como é que a nova maneira
sustentável no marco do plano do mar
aquele ali a única certeza que quando a
gente vai para o mar tem algo vai dar
errado eu não sei só o que quando e como
mas a única certeza que eu tenho é que
alguma coisa vai dar errado e eu diria
até que na nossa vida né
quando a certeza que a gente tem alguma
coisa errada
quando o qual como se na universidade eu
ficar estressado ou perder o período que
a moça ele acabou de falar que ficou
preocupada na formatura dela alguma
coisa vai dar errada a gente tem que
estar preparado pra isso então qual
outro desafio
como é que eu vou inovar numa indústria
que é por princípio conservadora porque
como é que eu me protejo de alqueva dão
errado só fazendo aquilo que eu conheço
só fazendo aquilo que já faça 300 anos e
dar certo ou não
ou então não adianta fazer nada eu sou
conservador não perde a calma vamos
trabalhar e vamos trabalhar de que
maneira eu botei um desafio para você só
quem está falando e marquinhos
hoje em dia a gente pega o celular do
navio e fala com qualquer lugar do mundo
usando a telefonia via satélite mas há
300 anos atrás é o único jeito de falar
de um navio para o outro distante usando
bandeirinha que é super sustentável no
desenho a bandeirinha lá e fica usando a
aula mas até hoje a gente usa suas
bandeirinhas
quando a gente está numa regata e que é
né se comunicar à comissão de regatas
comunica quando a então cada bandeirinha
dessa representa uma letra porque nós e
passa a mensagem cada letra representa
uma palavra tão bacana e foi criada
pelos antigos gente esperta né
os antigos é o mais perto que a gente
mas quem quer sair bandeirinha significa
o alho é com charlie
ou seja aquela bandeirinha lá é
representa a letra é e essa bandeira do
lado de cá representa a letra c o que eu
sempre falei pra rapaziada vamos fazer
um trabalho é o charlie que é puxado
é um trabalho que é empreendendo com
conhecimento a gente só vai superar o
desafio se a gente empreender a gente
ficar parado aqui como alguém né
comentou aqui no sofã na última
apresentação a gente não vai sair do
lugar
ok mas não adianta apenas empreender por
empreender isso entusiasmo
a gente só resolve os problemas se a
gente tiver conhecimento ea universidade
da parte desse conhecimento afinal de
contas eu sou da academia e eu tenho a
consciência que eu dou apenas uma
pequena parte desse conhecimento
o mundo a vida é que vai dar o restante
do desconhecimento então vamos sair da
caixa por vamos enfrentar o mundo ele é
difícil
a mostra que já me esqueci o nome dela
aqui estava anteriormente aqui eu vou
contar o que aconteceu comigo quando me
formei no último período da faculdade eu
tava também numa empresa já tinha me
prometido prometido que eu me contratar
eu falei assim bom tranquilo preciso me
informar então que o pessoal falou pra
mim da empresa alexandre terminou a sua
universidade vai embora para casa sai do
estádio vai embora para casa
termina seu projeto não se o tc a gente
volta aqui pra te contratar falei
maravilha sair do estágio foi que o
último período da faculdade só me
concentrando em tudo que eu tinha que
fazer
terminei no tempo certo e voltei lá o
cara falou que assina os documentos aqui
semana que vem você está trabalhando é
perfeito
fiquei uma semana em casa descansando
cheguei na segunda feira para trabalhar
o pessoal não espera aí porque o nosso
diretor em uma reunião de duas horas
esperando o diretor assumiu ele foi
pegou junto com a frança empreenderá uma
empresa francesa que eu faço não tem
problema rapaz
existe um pratica aqui o diretor tem
conversar com você que inclusive
conhecia quando ele voltar da frança
tranquilo você começa a trabalhar
segunda-feira que vem
perfeito foi pra casa relaxei praia e já
cheguei na segunda feira que vem
olha só o diretor da frança
a instrução que recebeu o que lhe fechou
as contratações
você está desempregado
eu era casado pagar o apartamento fazia
consultoria estava fazendo mestrado
ganha bolsa de mestrado tinha largado
tudo isso para ser contratado pela
empresa a vida é dura
o chefe quer que eu diga foi a melhor
coisa aconteceu pra mim porque anos
depois eu percebi que aquilo foi uma
maneira dura de me dizer que o lugar na
empresa
seu lugar é na universidade seis meses
depois abrir um concurso para a
universidade eu fiz o concurso passei e
desde então eu sou professor
então assim no irão mas só quem não
entende isso rapidinho não vemos dez
anos pra entender
é o motorzinho aqui de partida lenta de
verão de 10 anos para entender mas eu
entendi que aquele foi a melhor coisa
que aconteceu na minha vida porque se eu
tivesse ficado na indústria talvez não
fosse tão feliz quanto eu sou hoje as
coisas na vida de moro mas a gente tem
que empreender
a gente não pode ficar parado roupa
desculpe é que volto aqui aqui então vou
dar dois exemplos aqui de coisas que eu
tenho muito prazer em ter participado na
primeira delas a equipe solar brasil que
a equipe solar dá o tempo todo fazendo
isso empreendendo com o conhecimento que
a equipe solar é uma equipe formada por
alunos que se propõe a fazer o que
embarcações movidas exclusivamente a
energia solar isso a inovação é isso é
sustentável é mas qual é o desafio
sabe quando chega de energia do sol na
terra que se a gente ficar parado na rua
e botar um medidor de energia por metro
quadrado chega a apenas mil ou ate de
energia
só que as placas solares que absorvem
esses mil atinge em média têm eficiência
de 20% então na verdade para usar só
sobram 200 duas lâmpadas de 100 watts eu
pegar aquela lâmpada de fortuna eu não
consigo manter funcionando o metro
quadrado do sol lá de fora
então chega muito pouco cara muito pouco
de energia solar aqui pra gente
apesar da gente se queimar na praia é
isso então que ele vá fazer desistir
falou não pô não dá a cara se não há
quase nada como é que eu vou pro pelo
navio cá que gasta 4 toneladas de
combustível por hora usando new age por
metro quadrado
esse é o desafio esse é o desafio mas
para vencer esse desafio seus
conhecimentos e ficar só na tentativa eu
não vou fazer nada então foi isso que a
equipe solar que surgiu em 2008 a 10
anos atrás até colocar um projeto bacana
que eu nem sabia mas poxa é isso mesmo
tem 10 anos e começou hoje e se essa
competição surgiu na holanda em 2006 um
grupo de engenheiros navais que gostavam
de barco logicamente barquinho pequeno e
resolveram fazer o seguinte é que a
gente consegue fazer um barco só com
energia solar para movimentar o pessoal
vamos fazer uma competição
mas só que bacana competição a região
que eles moram na holanda uma região que
no inverno congela os canais e tem uma
competição diz que o pessoal quis que
anda entre as cidade
ele falou então no verão quando a gente
não consegue andar diz que é o que a
gente quer fazer vamos fazer essa
competição de barco
mas para ser diferente o barco solar
barcos movidos exclusivamente a energia
solar
o primeiro barco e apareceu lá andava 5
nós de velocidade máxima aquele nosso
barco ali
ana 15 ou seja em menos de dez anos a
gente triplicou a velocidade do barco e
na europa barco solar é uma realidade
você compra de compra baixo lá você já
pode botar um bar solar na sua casa e
botar ele pra andar pois aqui no brasil
a gente acha que não existe mas existe é
verdade mas tem muitos desafios
associados mas qual foi o maior desafio
é fazer a garotada entender que tem que
empreender com conhecimento e eu insisti
tanto que eles empreendessem que aquela
turminha tem algum alguma luz em aqui é
o do meio opa ó camarada hoje aqui é
dono da empresa junto com esse camarada
aqui esse cara se eu estou falando aqui
tem mais empresas
esse cara aqui também a empresa esse
cara aqui também a empresa esse cara
aqui também a empresa esse garoto aqui
esse aqui é uma empresa junto com o
cabeludo olha o trabalho que eles
fizeram a equipe eles aprenderam tanto a
empreender e eu empurrei tanto eles
nessa direção já são três empresas
incubadas naturalmente nesse projeto e
funcionando todas as três empresas e
trabalhando com aquilo que eles fizeram
no projeto empresa que trabalha com
administração de projetos que desse
garoto empresa quer trabalhar com a
parte elétrica e do piloto aqui também
tem a empresa trabalha com a parte
compósitos que é o que a gente faz o
barco barra de fibra de vidro
então é isso aí pessoal é a grande
mensagem que quero deixar para vocês
inovar hoje em dia não é importante
fundamental inovar para tornar nossa
vida mais sustentável a nossa
sobrevivência
futuro mas não dá pra ficar somente hoje
a ásia tem que estudar tem que pensar
tem que refletir tem que ler tem que
participar dessas coisas aqui pra abrir
a nossa cabeça para outros mundos e
outros universos que a gente nem sabe
que existem mas que estão do lado da
gente
ok e aí eu acho o seguinte cara acho que
não dá só para pegar a garotada que está
na faculdade casa a gente tem que pegar
isso um garoto que está aprendendo a
escrever então qual é o projeto que a
gente há alguns anos atrás propôs
será que é essa que a região de angra em
angra tem muita criança que vai pra
escola de barco
ela mora no continente mas a escola na
ilha negócio até esquisito quando me
falaram disso achei que fosse contrário
morasse na ilha e estudava no continente
ao contrário a escola é na ilha e ela
vai num barco a motor a gasolina lá
queimando gasolina o cheiro horroroso no
button andou de barco e sentou do cheiro
de gasolina qual foi nessa idéia
vamos usar esse projeto não é para
resolver o problema das prefeituras foi
uma licitação que a prefeitura fez a
gente nem participou porque sabia que ia
ganhar porque o barco seria mais caro do
que o bar convencional mas assim será
que o grande objetivo não é além de
satisfazer a demanda de transporte
permite que uma criança que está indo
para a escola já tenha contato com algo
que seja renovável com algo que seja
sustentável e essa idéia partiu de onde
partiu do meu filho de 8 anos e que
vocês estão com a moral muito grande
porque eu deixei de levar no jogo de
futebol é um jogo até serginho a
qualidade dele pataky o coitadinho
instalada aqui vou sair correndo e ele
vai ter outro jogo né
hoje em dia eu sou motorista do jogador
talvez eu esteja investindo na minha
aposentadoria não sei né
vamos lá então ela só eu pensei nesse
projeto de forma mais séria quando o meu
filho chegou em casa
aliás eu estava com ele a gente saiu de
carro e ele reclamou de um ônibus que
estava soltando uma fumaça preta
nessa época eu tinha 7 anos estava no
primeiro ano eu falei rapaz porque você
está reclamando disso ele não papai que
na minha aula de ciências
a professora disse que isso não é legal
eu falei poxa vida meu filho tem um ano
no primeiro ano que estamos estudando na
escola onde estuda ciências e à primeira
disciplina de ciências é meio ambiente
uau o mundo está mudando está mudando
bacana porque está mudando com a
garotada que está lá imagina o meu filho
todo mundo a turma dele quando tinha 15
anos
para ele ser sustentável é que nem
respirar é o normal então esse projeto
nasceu disso então qual foi a ideia
imagina que a gente faça uma embarcação
solar que não gasta nenhum tipo de
combustível se faltar ao sol eu espero
esse barco na tomada no cais e carrega
as baterias dele e ele continua andando
só na electricidade que um barco solar
na verdade um barco elétrico eo material
do barco é plástico a gente faz barco de
plástico
a fibra de vidro ou plástico só isso
aqui é outro tipo de plástico só que
esse plástico ele além de reciclável é
renovável porque é feito a partir da
cana-de-açúcar
ele é um plástico que ainda é feito de
petróleo mas já existe uma metodologia
comercial o brasil é o maior fabricante
desse tipo de plástico no mundo quer
saber
olha só a gente acha que a gente joga
bola não a gente faz coisa legal
o empreendedorismo e conhecimento então
olha que bacana imagina que pegar um
barco que ele é todo reciclável todo
renovável colocam a criança de 7 8 9 e
10 anos nele e levar essa criança todo
dia e trazê la de volta à escola
aí eu vou ter certeza que o mundo está
mudando e muito mais rápido do que a
gente já percebeu até hoje em dia
então a gente tem que perceber o que é
pessoal a gente tem que perceber onde
está aqui o botãozinho para outubro
só falta o último
a gente precisa inovar com
empreendedorismo inovar
desculpe empreender com o conhecimento
porque empreender é que a liberdade
a gente tem que ter liberdade para ver
se alguém chegar pra gente diz é que a
gente não pode a gente não sai do lugar
mas qual é a base da liberdade mas dá
liberdade é conhecimento conhecimento
nos torna livres para que a gente possa
fazer o que a gente quiser
ok muito obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]